En este video vamos a hablar de funciones
químicas inorgánicas y de sus compuestos.
Todos usamos compuestos químicos en nuestra vida
cotidiana, como la sal de mesa o algunos ungüentos
para curar heridas. Algunos compuestos tienen
propiedades químicas y composiciones en común,
esto es algo que los va a diferenciar de otros.
Y a los conjuntos de compuestos químicos con
propiedades y composiciones semejantes les
llamamos Funciones químicas, las cuales se
dividen en orgánicas e inorgánicas. Por ahora sólo
vamos a hablar de las inorgánicas. Las funciones
químicas inorgánicas de mayor importancia son
Hidruros, Óxidos, Hidróxidos, Ácidos y Sales. Y
se clasifican con base en dos criterios: primero,
por su origen: son Oxigenadas si derivan de óxidos
y son Hidrogenadas si derivan de hidruros; el
segundo criterio es por el elemento químico
que reacciona en el compuesto: si es metal o si
es no metal. Veamos primero cómo se forman los
Compuestos oxigenados y cuál es su nomenclatura.
Los óxidos son compuestos binarios formados por
Oxígeno y otro elemento que puede ser metal o
no metal, en los cuales el número de oxidación
del Oxígeno es -2 y el otro elemento tiene un
número de oxidación positivo. Si el concepto
del número de oxidación no te resulta familiar
o no lo recuerdas, te invito a revisar primero
este tema en Khan Academy. Los óxidos reciben su
nombre por el elemento que acompaña al Oxígeno,
normalmente son óxidos de.. el elemento. Por
ejemplo, Óxido de sodio. La excepción a esta
regla es el compuesto de Hidrógeno, H₂O, al que
simplemente llamamos agua. Para escribirlos,
primero se coloca el símbolo del elemento
oxidado seguido del símbolo del Oxígeno;
el elemento oxidado recibe la valencia 2
del Oxígeno como subíndice y el Oxígeno la
valencia del elemento oxidado, o ambos subíndices
se simplifican si son pares. Es decir, continuando
con el ejemplo del Óxido de sodio, escribimos
primero el símbolo del Sodio con subíndice 2 y
después el símbolo del Oxígeno, como la valencia
del Sodio es 1 el Oxígeno no lleva subíndice. En
el caso del Óxido de azufre, tanto el Oxígeno
como el Azufre tienen valencia par, entonces
se simplifican los subíndices así: Dióxido de
azufre. Pasa lo mismo con el Dióxido de plomo.
Ojo, en el caso del Plomo, al ser
un metal el elemento que reacciona,
se forma un Óxido básico. En el primer caso el
Azufre es un no metal, entonces se forma un óxido
ácido o anhídrido, es decir, sin Hidrógeno.
Es importante no olvidar que en este tipo de
compuestos el Oxígeno se encuentra con número de
oxidación -2, por ejemplo Anhídrido sulfuroso,
y si agregamos una molécula de agua aquí, veremos
que se formará un Hidróxido. Este grupo de
compuestos se conforma por este Óxido básico y un
grupo funcional hidroxilo OH que se obtiene de la
molécula de agua y que tiene número de oxidación
-1. A los Hidróxidos de los metales alcalinos
como Litio, Sodio, Potasio, Rubidio y Cesio se
les llama Álcalis, son muy solubles en el agua,
tóxicos y venenosos. Los Hidróxidos poseen
propiedades básicas, por ello se les llama
también bases. La nomenclatura tradicional de
los Hidróxidos se realiza de forma similar a la
de los Óxidos básicos. Por ejemplo, el Hidróxido
cúprico, que se forma con el símbolo del Cobre y
el hidroxilo, con subíndice 2, ya que el número
de oxidación del Cobre en este caso es +2,
aunque puede actuar con número de oxidación +1,
formando entonces el Hidróxido cuproso. Recuerda,
el grupo hidroxilo actúa con número de
oxidación -1. Pero también existe otra
nomenclatura llamada de STOCK o IUPAC, que
emplea el número de oxidación del metal,
como en este caso donde el Cromo tiene un número
de oxidación +3, Hidróxido de cromo (III).
Pero si es un Óxido ácido o Anhídrido al
que le agregamos una molécula de agua,
entonces se formará un compuesto de tres
elementos llamado Ácido oxácido. La fórmula
general de los ácidos oxácidos es: H₂O +
Nm₂ Oₓ = Hₐ Nmb Oc, donde H es el Hidrógeno,
Nm = no metal y O = Oxígeno; por ejemplo,
el Ácido sulfúrico, donde el no metal es el
Azufre. La nomenclatura de los oxácidos, así
como la de los óxidos e hidróxidos, se basa
en la nomenclatura tradicional que relaciona la
valencia del no metal con un prefijo y un sufijo,
como aparecen en esta tabla. Para las valencias
1 y 2 el prefijo es Hipo_ y el sufijo _oso,
como en el Anhídrido hipoyodoso; con valencia
de 3 y 4 no hay prefijo, y el sufijo es _oso,
por ejemplo Anhídrido yodoso; para valencia 5 y
6, el sufijo es _ico, como en Anhídrido yódico,
y para valencia 7 el prefijo es per_ y el
sufijo _ico, como el Anhídrido peryódico.
Muy bien, para terminar con este grupo de
compuestos oxigenados, veamos las sales oxisales.
Cuando un Oxiácido y un hidróxido reaccionan
se neutralizan y forman una Oxisal más agua,
es decir, el Hidrógeno del oxiácido se sustituye
con el ion metálico como Sodio, o no metálico
como Amonio, y así se forma una oxisal. Estas
pueden ser Neutras si todos los hidrógenos son
sustituidos, Ácidas si sólo se sustituye parte
de los hidrógenos, Básicas si sólo se sustituye
una parte del grupo hidroxilo OH, Dobles si el
oxiácido reacciona con 2 hidróxidos distintos,
e Hidratadas cuando poseen moléculas de agua de
hidratación o cristalización. La nomenclatura
tradicional de las oxisales se forma a partir
del ácido del que proviene y se cambia el sufijo
_oso por _hito y el _ico por _ato. Por ejemplo,
Fe₂ (SO₄)₃ procede del H₂SO₄, Ácido sulfúrico:
sustituimos sulfúrico por sulfato por lo que
la sal se denomina Fe₂ (SO₄)₃, Sulfato férrico.
Recordemos que la terminación _ico en férrico
está relacionada con el número de oxidación del
elemento en este compuesto, que es 3 en este
caso. Estos fueron los compuestos oxigenados.
Ahora veamos los Compuestos hidrogenados.
Habíamos dicho que son los que se forman por
una combinación de un elemento, metal o no metal,
con Hidrógeno; eso también se llama Reducción. A
las reducciones de Hidrógeno con un metal de
transición se les llama Hidruros metálicos,
en donde el Hidrógeno va a tener el número de
oxidación -1. Los Hidruros metálicos, por lo
general, son sólidos a temperatura ambiental.
Para nombrar los hidruros metálicos se emplean
la nomenclatura de STOCK y la nomenclatura
Sistemática, de hecho siguen la misma regla
general de los óxidos para su nomenclatura, donde
se señala el número de hidrógenos, por ejemplo de
Hidruro de calcio. Cuando se unen químicamente dos
Hidruros metálicos se forman Hidruros dobles, que
se nombran indicando el vocablo doble antes del
nombre de los metales. Los Hidruros no metálicos
en cambio utilizan una nomenclatura diferente,
en la que se emplean nombres comunes como CH₄,
llamado comúnmente Metano -también se le puede
llamar Tetrahidruro de carbono, pero esto no
es común. En los Hidruros no metálicos el
Hidrógeno tiene un número de oxidación +1.
Los Hidrácidos, también llamados Ácidos hidrácidos
o Ácidos binarios, se forman a partir de la
combinación de Hidrógeno con halógenos del Grupo
VII A: Hierro, Cloro, Bromo, Yodo; o calcógenos,
elementos no metálicos de los Grupos VI A: Azufre,
Selenio, Telurio; éstos actúan con valencia de 1 y
2, respectivamente. Estos compuestos carecen de
Oxígeno. La nomenclatura tradicional establece
que se coloque el nombre genérico Ácido, seguido
del nombre del no metal, terminando en el sufijo
_hídrico, más usado en solución acuosa, como Ácido
clorhídrico. La nomenclatura Sistemática emplea el
sufijo _uro para nombrar el anión y a continuación
se nombra el catión: Cloruro de hidrógeno.
Por último, veamos las Sales haloideas. Son
derivados de un ácido hidrácido y un hidróxido,
como la reacción entre el Hidróxido de
Sodio y el Ácido clorhídrico. Éstas,
a diferencia de las oxisales, carecen de Oxígeno,
y se conforman por un metal y un no metal.
En este ejemplo el resultado es Cloruro de
sodio o sal de mesa. Para su nomenclatura el no
metal adopta la terminación _uro y el metal la
terminación _ico u _oso siguiendo las reglas
de los números de oxidación en esta tabla.
Como se ha mencionado antes, para escribir
la fórmula de estas sales se intercambian
los números de oxidación Na +1, Cl
-1, igual a Na₁Cl₁. En este caso,
al ser el valor 1 no es necesario escribirlos.
Otro ejemplo, para aclarar la nomenclatura,
es el Cloruro de magnesio 1, donde el no metal
se menciona con el sufijo _uro y el metal es
seguido por su número de oxidación; siguen las
mismas reglas de la nomenclatura STOCK o IUPAC.
Este ha sido un video con
mucha información importante,
por ahora lo dejaremos aquí.
Nos vemos en el siguiente video.